oh
what
foreign
off we go
adventure time
master d luke pyma has something
important to tell you
yes
about kaya
i should have known he would see this as
the perfect opportunity to get back at
me
sounds like there's a bit of bad blood
between you guys then
i shan't get into that now
more importantly the knights of fivonius
are responding more or less as i had
anticipated
all we need to do now is think of a
counter plan
that won't work
it will only arouse the night's
suspicion if i don't show up as they're
expecting
that's what kaya is counting on
hmm
so what are we gonna do
patience
let me think for a moment
hmm
if they intend to monitor me then so be
it
we can use this to create the perfect
alibi
what's in a labla an alibi
if you want to find out maybe you can do
me a small favor first
oh come on why do you love cliffhangers
so much
in monstat mist flowers are most
commonly found in a region just
northwest of the winery
if you could gather some for me i'd be
most grateful
i will make other preparations here in
the meantime
off we go
ah you're back
allow me to introduce the wineries
master brewer
so many missed flowers
great
i can't wait to see how this turns out
so
are you certain the equipment can
withstand this level of purity oh my my
goodness
the winery owner himself is addressing
me directly
don't worry sir it is always my honor to
serve you even if it means risking my
life
huh
what's so life-threatening about this
please excuse me
i must get to work
what's he gonna do with a bunch of miss
flowers
long story short
a few days ago the winery was
experimenting with some new flavors they
wanted to see if mist flour can truly
add a crisp and refreshing taste sure
enough they discovered that the flowers
extract is truly potent so the new batch
is selling like hotcakes
no not potent in terms of attracting
customers
but slimes slimes need to extract
elemental energy to survive
for them this substance is simply
irresistible so i thought to myself
i wonder how much trouble i could cause
now that i know this
[Music]
yikes what was that noise oh
cold
so cold
oh master d luke purification complete
sir
but the equipment is
marvelous work
don't fret about the equipment i shall
have my butler order more immediately
marvelous jelly hoe spiffing somebody
fetched the butler pilot never knew you
had to be so well spoken to get a job in
the alcohol industry this is what i was
talking about mist flour extract
or for our purposes
elemental bait wow
it really has a strong elemental
lift
can we test it out sprinkle a little on
the ground over there
careful just a small amount
and then
that's it how long does it take before
holy moly it really does attract slimes
and even more than we expected it
appears the potency is greater than
anticipated we better get rid of them
before they wreak havoc on the manor
everybody stand back
adventure time
no
escape off we go
adventure time
teamwork is dreamworks
let's light it up
such a powerful effect from such a small
amount of extract
at least we didn't go picking
wildflowers for nothing all right so can
you tell us what your plan is now master
d luke yes
the plan is
and so i expect it to all go down
without a hitch
are you sure it will work you're the
only person in the plan i have
persevered alone from the start now i
alone must face what lies ahead well if
you already made up your mind but until
that moment comes we can still help you
out where we can isn't that right i am
indeed indebted to you
let's wait until evening to meet mr d
look at the tavern
adventure time
off we go
come in take a seat
we have a few specials today
come take a look
greetings mr huffman of the knights of
fabonius
to what do i owe the pleasure at this
hour
oh
uh
nothing
i'm merely procrastinating
i thought i might indulge myself with a
beverage or two
ah traveler
fancy meeting you here
oh we were in the mood for an evening
stroll what would you like to drink
i'll have a
dandelion wine i suppose
oh pilot wants apple juice
oh
but my mom forgot to bring her a coin
pouch
do you have any more on you apologies we
do not give credit here well in that
case let this be my treat
no need we'll be back in a jiffy
huffman showed up just as expected
okay remember the plan go to the city
side gate and place the elemental bait
whoa
you used all of it
this is gonna be pretty epic
yikes here comes the slimes quick let's
get to the tavern before anyone spots us
counting kaya is no doubt a formidable
knight but he also brings us more than
his share of hassle
uh no no this isn't right i should not
be talking about my superior in such a
manner
if he were to overhear me
we're back is my apple juice ready
one moment
mr huffman mr huffman a situation at the
side gate everyone to the side gate
what is it what happened
it's
slimes mr huffman
slimes
you see them all the time what's the big
panic
we do but
sir
there are more slimes out there now than
all the slimes i've seen in my life
added together
oh
wow
surely this couldn't be the abysswater
secret weapon but
i have another matter to attend to here
oh
the matter of your dandelion wine no no
i i uh that's not what i meant
so this is how the knights of favonius
conduct themselves in a crisis the abyss
order is encroaching on the city gates
and your response is to sit here
drinking wine it's like i've always said
the knights are not to be trusted i
uh
master g luke is right
my conduct here has been
below par i shall set off at once but
first
may i have a quiet word
huh
keep your voice down
i presume you know what this is about
please watch dee look for me do not let
him leave under any circumstances i must
head to the side gate but i'll be back
shortly
i'm counting on you
good
that's him out of the way everything's
going according to plan i must get going
too i won't have a second despair if i'm
to be back in time
so
ah
there you are
dealing with you will be the easy part
[Applause]
hmm
no one escapes my sights
[Applause]
furniture
burn
sorry
freeze classic master d luke not a
baddie left standing nothing more than a
few hilly churros no time to chat i
don't know how long those slimes will
keep huffman occupied best get back to
the tavern
oh
glad that's settled
let's get back to the tavern
do you think huffman is back yet
adventure time
come take a look
it seems huffman hasn't yet returned we
made it in time
the situation is sorted now
i never expected that the abyss orders
army would turn out to be nothing more
than a few slimes that is a surprise
perhaps the night's true calling is to
be slime exterminators
who knows
domestic pest control may turn out to be
a more valuable use of your resources
master g luke please have you no respect
at all how come you're sweating so much
you didn't leave did you
is that so
but why now of all times for the love of
barbados
uh-oh huffman is getting
hmm
excuse me sir might i be so bold as to
inquire
did you see master d luke uh i mean
today's bartender
did you see him leave just now yikes
he's asking other customers master d
luke
why
no
he's been behind the bar this entire
time i see mr huffman you ought to get
back after this
send my regards to the rest of the
nights oh
never mind i must be going i should
report back here take this as a token of
my esteem
hmm
how odd
that was too close plymouth sure we were
toast i foresaw this eventuality so all
the guests here tonight save you two
are my own people from the don winery
they're all in on it not all of them
or should i say
not all of us kyah where did you come
from i just picked a good spot to
quietly sit and watch the show
you've been here this whole time correct
the dark knight heroes alibi
i think it's my favorite chapter so far
more intriguing than a fine wine
so
you plan to report everything to the
knights of evonius
come now d luke you know me better than
that
i have no interest in exposing secrets i
was just curious to see how far
monstat's dark knight hero would really
go and you did not disappoint i have
nothing to prove to you
oh naturally i must say though one thing
i didn't see coming is that the mighty
dark knight hero would actually need
help from other peeps sorry we're
closing all right all right
i have no further need of wine to
entertain myself tonight in any case
just one last thing before i go it had
better be the very last thing i feel
strangely comforted by the fact you now
have an assistant t luke
i hope you all have a wonderful night
what was all that about
don't mind him thank you for all your
help with this matter
this is a token of my gratitude wow
thanks mr d luke i'm in the habit of
working alone
but
i did enjoy having your assistance this
time in the future if there's anything
you ever need
you can come to me for help